i
[Música]
ah
en panamá la comunidad del g20 decidió
llevar el activismo de las redes
sociales a las calles para llamar la
atención de las autoridades y para
conmemorar el día internacional contra
la homofobia la opinión de esta
población sobre su situación es bastante
generalizada pues se sienten
invisibilizados manifiestan que hay un
silencio de parte del estado alrededor
de las luchas a favor de sus derechos
por ejemplo esperan una decisión sobre
la primera demanda que se introdujo en
la corte suprema de justicia en 2016
sobre la inconstitucionalidad de
prohibir la unión de personas del mismo
sexo tema que abrió las puertas de la
confrontación entre un grupo de
conservadores incluyendo la iglesia
católica panameña y la comunidad tlgb y
aunado a esto permanece una solicitud de
ley de identidad de género que entre
otras cosas pretende contrarrestar actos
discriminatorios como los que se
presentaron con las restricciones de
circulación de género por día debido a
la pandemia
[Música]
además de la conmemoración internacional
en méxico desde hace dos años se declaró
oficialmente el 17 de mayo como día
nacional contra la homofobia lesbofobia
transfobia y bifobia sin embargo la
situación de este segmento de la
población no parece mejorar el consejo
nacional para prevenir la discriminación
dio a conocer que en los últimos tres
años ha erradicado 182 quejas de
personas de la diversidad sexual por
actos de discriminación principalmente
en el ámbito laboral en esta ocasión si
bien hay actividades presenciales que
comenzaron incluso la víspera como la
rodada ciclista por tres alcaldías de la
capital del país la mayoría de los
eventos son virtuales como el festival
por la diversidad sexual de soto en 2021
que incluye espectáculos musicales o
bien ciclos de conferencias y
conversatorios como el que organiza la
suprema corte de justicia entre otros
actos culturales
[Música]
intensas protestas ha generado en italia
un proyecto de ley contra la
discriminación de las personas
homosexuales el pasado fin de semana en
milán siempre se enfrentaron partidarios
y oponentes de esta ley grupos de apoyo
a la comunidad lgtb plus y oponentes
ligados a grupos de ultraderecha el
proyecto de ley contiene medidas de
prevención y para proteger a las
personas homosexuales transexuales y a
las mujeres se modifica el código penal
integrando la circunstancia agravante
por discriminación por razones de
identidad de género o de orientación
sexual de esta manera los delitos de
homofobia transfobia y misoginia podrían
ser castigados con penas de hasta 4 años
de cárcel por el momento este texto está
estancado en el parlamento italiano ya
fue aprobado en la cámara de diputados
pero aún se espera en la luz verde del
senado para su aprobación
[Música]